Frühjahr 2020. Immer häufiger begegnen wir
diesem Buchstaben.
Q. Auf der Straße.
Q. Im Internet.
Dahinter steckt eine schier unglaubliche Verschwörungstheorie.
Mit prominenten Verbreitern.
“Es kommen immer mehr Details ans Licht”
“QAnon” Anhänger glauben an pädophile
Eliten und dass diese gedeckt werden – von
einem Feind: dem tiefen Staat.
Für QAnon-Anhänger wie ihn ist Donald Trump
der Auserwählte - ihr Verbündeter im Kampf
gegen die Eliten.
Manche sind in dieser Auseinandersetzung sogar
bereit zu töten.
Auch in Deutschland gewinnt die Theorie immer
mehr Anhänger, die sich in Telegramgruppen
unter sich fühlen.
– Also wenn Zeit für einen Putsch ist, dann ist es jetzt.
– Leider glaube ich
nicht, dass die Sicherheitsbehörden die Bedrohung,
die von QAnon ausgeht, auf dem Schirm haben.
Wie gefährlich kann eine Verschwörungstheorie
werden?
Wenn man wirklich in dieser Welt sich bewegt,
dann ist Gewalt ja oft das letzte Mittel.
Um zu verstehen, wie QAnon in die Welt kam,
müssen wir zurück in das Jahr 2017 - auf
die Seite eines Imageboards, das auch Rechtsextreme
für ihre Propaganda nutzen.
Ein unbekannter Nutzer gibt sich dort als
hochrangiger Informant aus dem engsten Kreis
um Donald Trump aus. Der vermeintliche Insider
nennt sich “Q”, seine Gefolgschaft “QAnon”,
kurz für “Anonymous”.
Er beginnt, kryptische Nachrichten zu veröffentlichen,
Rätsel, angeblich voller geheimer Informationen
über Donald Trumps Kampf gegen eine große
Verschwörung satanistischer, Kinder mordender
Eliten.
Was und wer steckt hinter dieser Verschwörungserzählung?
Videoanruf bei einem, der es wissen muss:
Der Journalist und Autor Mike Rothschild ist Experte für
QAnon in den USA.
Die Nachrichten, die der angebliche Nutzer
“Q” hinterlässt, werden in der Szene
als “QDrops” bezeichnet. Für Außenstehende kaum zu verstehen.
Wirre Versatzstücke einer Verschwörungserzählung.
Was die Botschaften aber so erfolgreich bei
ihren Anhängern macht: Sie schaffen kleine
Rästel, eine Verschwörungserzählung zum
Mitmachen.
Die Entschlüssler*innen der “QDrops”
glauben, ein weltweites pädophiles Netzwerk
enttarnt zu haben. Ihnen geht es nicht um
reale Verbrechen an Kindern, die es ja tatsächlich
gibt.
Stattdessen glauben sie, Angehörige der Elite
würden Kinder in unterirdischen Lagern foltern,
um aus ihrem Blut ein Mittel zu gewinnen,
das der Elite als Lebenselexier dient: Adrenochrom.
In Deutschland verbreitet auch Xavier Naidoo
solche Erzählungen.
“Adrenochrom. Geht auf Adrenochrom - Bilder,
wenn ihr das ertragen könnt.
Bekanntheit erlangte Adrenochrom vor allem
durch die Popkultur. In dem Kinofillm “Fear
and Loathing in Las Vegas” berauscht sich
der Protagonist Raoul Duke angeblich an Adrenochrom.
“Es gibt nur eine Quelle für dieses Zeug,
und zwar die Nebenniere eines lebenden menschlichen
Körpers.”
Reine Fiktion. Doch den Verschwörungsgläubigen
gilt sogar dieser Spielfilm als Beweis für
die Theorie ums Kinderblut. .
Tatsächlich ist Adrenochrom schlicht ein
Oxidationsprodukt von Adrenalin, kann synthetisch
hergestellt und einfach im Internet bestellt
werden. Wie hier.
Man braucht also kein Kinderblut.
Die angeblich berauschende Wirkung von Adrenochrom:
wissenschaftlich unbewiesen.
Eine Idee aus einer Romanverfilmung, völlig
unbelegt. Warum glauben auch in Deutschland
Menschen daran? Wir besuchen mehrere Demonstrationen
gegen die Corona-Schutzmaßnahmen.
Viele der Teilnehmer*innen verbreiten Verschwörungserzählungen.
Manche sehen aus wie Hippies. Auch Rechtsextreme sind dabei. Und dazwischen -
immer wieder Menschen mit Q-Zeichen - wir fragen sie, was es damit auf sich hat.
– Sie haben ja ein Q auf Ihrer
Kleidung. Können Sie erklären, was es damit
auf sich hat?
– Muss ich nicht unbedingt
erklären. Das ist ja praktisch... selbsterklärend. Wer sich
damit beschäftigt.
Für die Liebe, für etwas sich einzusetzen, das
ist für mich die QBewegung.
Es ist natürlich ne sehr abstruse Vorstellung,
Ja... Es liegt bei jedem selbst, ob man es
glauben mag oder nicht. Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass es so eine Art Droge sein könnte, die
wie LSD wirkt, wenn dieses Adreno-, Adrenalin
mit Luft oxidiert, dass es dann zu Adrenochrom wird.
Ein Run auf eine Verschwörungserzählung,
die so abstrus klingt? Warum? Wir besuchen
Pia Lamberty. Sie ist Psychologin und forscht
zu Verschwörungsmythen, auch zu QAnon.
Ich glaube QAnon ist ein bisschen
wie der Prototyp eigentlich einer Verschwörungserzählung.
Es geht ja bei so Verschwörungserzählungen
darum, sich selber zu erhöhen. dass man vielleicht
die Person ist, die die Wahrheit herausfindet,
dass sie vielleicht auch so ein gewisses Heldentum
zelebrieren können, was sie vielleicht auf anderen
Ebenen nicht schaffen.
Dass Verschwörungsmythen gerade jetzt großen
Zulauf bekommen ist für Pia Lamberty nicht
überraschend.
-- Allgemein ist es so, dass Menschen
vor allem dann an Verschwörungen glauben,
wenn sie einen Kontrollverlust erleben.
Ein plötzliches Ende der Partnerschaft
beispielsweise, ein Jobverlust, aber eben
auch eine gesellschaftliche Krise. Eine globale
Pandemie, wie wir sie gerade haben, können
da Faktoren sein, die das noch einmal begünstigen.
Wir zeigen Lamberty unsere Recherchen, sprechen
auch über Xavier Naidoo mit ihr.
QAnon ist ist nicht die erste Verschwörungserzählung,
der Naidoo eine Plattform gibt. Trotzdem haben
Fernsehsender ihm jahrelang eine Bühne gegeben,
haben zahlreiche Prominente ihn gegen Kritik
in Schutz genommen.
Wenn eine populäre Person
wie Xavier Naidoo solche Dinge bewirbt, das
ist nochmal eine extra Gefahr. Eine Person,
die unglaublich viele Anhänger hat, die ihm
ja auch irgendwo vertrauen, die ihn vielleicht
auch bewundern.
Als er im März 2020 einen Song postet, in
dem er Stimmung gegen Geflüchtete macht,
verliert er seinen Vertrag beim Privatfernsehen.
Seither nutzt er intensiv Telegram – auch
zum Verbreiten von Verschwörungserzählungen
wie QAnon.
Und wenn man bedenkt, dass Telegram ist ja
gerade der Kanal, der am meisten genutzt wird.
Das ist ja auch nochmal anders, als wenn man
Benachrichtigungen bekommt auf Facebook. Dass
ist auf dem Handy zwischen privaten Nachrichten,
vielleicht zwischen Familienchat und der Nachricht
vom Partner poppt dann auf einmal eine Nachricht
von Xavier Naidoo auf. Ich glaube, das wirkt
nochmal emotionaler und nochmal stärker und
Der Verschwörungs-Content des Sängers kommt
an. Über 80 000 Abonnenten folgen Naidoo.
"Servus ihr Lieben, ich richte
mich an alle interessierten Menschen da draußen,
interessiert an der Wahrheit.
Ich hab vieles gesehen,
was bei Q passt, viele Wahrheiten sind ans
Licht getreten.”
Naidoo teilt in seinem Telegrammkanal auch
Inhalte des größten Deutschen Q-Anon-Kanals:
Qlobal change.
Diese Botschaft richtet sich
an alle Menschen, für die diese Maske den
Widerstand symbolisiert. Wir brauchen euch.
Der Staat hat uns den Krieg erklärt.
Einen schmutzigen Krieg.
Wir werden uns nicht verstecken, wir werden kämpfen.
Eine Kriegserklärung an Staat und Regierung.
Der Kanal hat über 90.000 Abonnent*innen
auf Youtube. Noch größer ist er in
der Messenger-App Telegram.
Mithilfe eines Datenexperten analysieren wir
verschiedene Telegram-Kanäle der deutschsprachigen
Q-Anon-Szene. Wer folgt ihnen und was wird
dort geteilt?
Unsere Analyse zeigt: Seit Mitte März, dem
Beginn der Corona Maßnahmen in Deutschland,
haben die größten Telegram-Kanäle der Szene
in einem rasanten Tempo neue Mitglieder gewonnen.
Auch Qlobal Change.
Über 100.000 Menschen folgen ihnen dort.
Die Gefolgschaft des Kanals hat sich seit
Anfang März vervierfacht.
In unserer Datenanalyse sehen auch: Corona
ist ein beliebtes Thema in der deutschsprachigen
„QAnon“-Szene.
Sechs der zehn meist gesehenen Nachrichten
des Kanals „Qlobal-Change“ haben mit der
Corona-Pandemie zu tun.
Auch in anderen „QAnon“-Gruppen auf Telegram
ist Corona eines der wichtigsten Themen. Beschwerden
über die Maskenpflicht vermischen sich dort
mit Lynchmord-Fantasien.
Neben Xavier Naidoo ist ein deutscher Akteur
besonders wichtig für die Verbreitung von
QAnon-Posts: Oliver Janich.
Früher schrieb er für das Magazin “Focus
Money”, heute lebt er auf den Philippinen
und arbeitet u.a. für das extrem rechte “Compact
Magazin”.
Er veröffentlicht regelmäßig Videos für
seine 146.000 Abonnent*innen auf Youtube.
Sie tragen Titel wie: “Die Coronakrise:
Eine satanische Freimaurer-Inszenierung?”
Oliver Janich: “Wir wissen, die Freimaurer
streben eine Weltregierung an, habe ich schon
zig Videos dazu gemacht,
alle Brüder vereinigt. Und Bill Gates strebt
eine Weltregierung an, hab ich auch schon
die Beweise gebracht.
Oliver Janich und Xavier Naidoo kennen sich
schon seit Jahren. Die beiden stehen im Austausch,
mehrfach hat der Sänger dem Blogger in den
vergangenen Monaten Interviews gegeben.
Oliver Janich: “Wenn die Leute wüssten,
worüber wir uns schon alles unterhalten,
das können wir immer leider nur stückchenweise
an die Öffentlichkeit bringen.”
Janich und Naidoo teilen offenbar ihren Hang
zu Verschwörungserzählungen. Naidoo fällt
bereits seit mehr als zehn Jahren mit Verschwörungsmythen
und einer Nähe zur rechtsextremen Reichsbürger-Bewegung auf.
Diese glauben, Deutschland sei ein besetztes
Land und sie lehnen die Verfassung ab. Schon
2011 sagte Naidoo im ARD Frühstücksfernsehen: " Nein, wir sind nicht frei, wir sind immer
noch ein besetztes Land, Deutschland hat keinen
Friedensvertrag und dementsprechend ist Deutschland
auch kein echtes Land“
Naidoos Songs wie “Raus aus dem Reichstag”
von 2009 laufen auf rechtsextremen Demonstrationen.
Verschwörungserzählungen sind für Rechtsextreme
besonders wichtig, sagt er:
– Verschwörungsideologen
und Rechtsextreme teilen sich zwei wichtige
Erzählungen. Zum einen gebe es eine geheime
Elite, die zum Schaden der Deutschen die Welt
lenken würde. Zum anderen werden dadurch
alle Medien gesteuert von dieser Elite, und
man kann nur der alternativen Presse trauen.
In diesem Weltbild sind sie vereint. Prinzipiell
funktionieren rechtsextreme Weltbilder nur
mit Verschwörungserzählungen.
Miro Dittrich ist Rechtsextremismusexperte.
Sein Job: Die dunklen Ecken des Internets
beobachten. Radikalisierung im Netz münde
immer häufiger in realer Gewalt. QAnon hält
er für besonders gefährlich.
– Ich halte das Risiko von Offline-Gewalt
von QAnon derzeit in all diesem Gemisch, das
wir sehen, tatsächlich für das Größte.
In USA ist diese Bewegung ja schon länger
aktiv. Wir sehen, dort haben sich Morde, Entführungen,
terroristische Anschläge gehäuft. Jetzt,
wo es in Deutschland eine breitere Masse erreicht
hat, wird das auch folgen.
2019 gab es in den USA zwei Morde durch QAnon-Anhänger.
Einer der Täter erschien vor Gericht mit
vielsagenden Kritzelein in der Hand. Dem Wahlspruch
Donald Trumps: Make America great again. Und:
einem Q.
Auch in Deutschland herrscht in den QAnon-Gruppen
teilweise blanker Hass.
Ein Gruppenmitglied schreibt über Politiker:
Ein anderer träumt sich den Putsch herbei:
"Wenn wir uns alle vereinen (...) und
alle nach Berlin kommen und dann diesen Bundestag
stürzen. (...) Dann ist es sowieso soweit,
dass ein Bürgerkrieg entsteht. Aber dann
muss man provozieren. (...)Ja, man muss putschen,
einfach man muss die Regierung stürzen."
Oliver Janich seinerseits droht Journalisten,
die kritisch über ihn und Naidoo berichten.
“Also falls es Tribunale gibt, ich sag’s
immer wieder, sind die Journalisten und vor
allem die Herausgeber und Chefredakteure ganz
oben auf der Liste.”
Auch Xavier Naidoo spielt in seiner Musik
– nicht erst seit ein paar Monaten – mit Drohungen
gegen Politiker.
Auf Telegram geht Oliver Janich im August
2018 noch weiter.
“Viele der Leute, die da heute an der Macht
sind, gehören eigentlich aufgehängt. Kann
man ja sonst nirgends sagen, hier kann man
sowas sagen.”
Wir konfrontieren Oliver Janich schriftlich
mit seiner Äußerung, wollen wissen, warum
er zu Gewalt aufruft.
Eine Antwort bekommen wir nicht.
Xavier Naidoo hatte sich in der Vergangenheit
gegen Gewalt ausgesprochen.
Wir fragen Naidoo schriftlich, bitten um ein
Interview.
Warum bewirbt er Ideologien, die zu Gewalt
führen und wie steht er zu Janichs Gewaltaufrufen?
Doch Naidoo antwortet nicht auf unsere Anfrage.
Aus Worten können auch in Deutschland Taten
werden. Und immer häufiger bieten Verschwörungsideologien
den Anlass für Terrorattacken.
Man sieht in Deutschland an Halle, an Hanau,
aber auch weltweit an Attentaten wie in Christchurch
dass Menschen Verschwörungserzählungen nutzen,
um ihre Taten zu legitimieren.
Beispiel Hanau.
In einem vor der Tat veröffentlichten Video
äußert der Täter Tobias R. Gedanken, die
an die QAnon Erzählung erinnern.
“In eurem Land gibt es sogenannte tiefe
Untergrund-Militärbasen. In manchen davon
huldigen sie dem Teufel selbst. Sie misshandeln,
foltern und töten kleine Kinder..”
PL: Man sieht sogar empirisch, dass der Glaube
an Verschwörungen und ich spreche hier vom
abstrakten Glauben an Verschwörungen schon
mit einer gesteigerten Gewaltaffinität einhergeht.
Dass diese Menschen sich mehr vom demokratischen
Diskurs abnabeln und stattdessen tatsächlich
auch eher gewalttätige politische Alternativen
suchen, um ihre eigene Wahrheit zu verkünden,
um ihre Ziele zu erreichen.
In den USA stufte das FBI “QAnon” schon
im Mai 2019 als mögliches Terrorrisiko ein.
Wie schätzen deutsche Sicherheitsbehörden
die Gefahr ein, die solche Verschwörungserzählungen
für die innere Sicherheit darstellen?
Wir fragen den Verfassungsschutz:
“Derartige Verschwörungstheorien können
sich zu einer Gefahr entwickeln ... Konkrete
Erkenntnisse .. liegen nicht vor.”
– Leider glaube ich nicht, dass die Behörden die Bedrohung, die von QAnon ausgeht, auf dem Schirm haben.
Wir haben das ganze ja schon mit den Reichsbürgern
damals gesehen, wie lange diese Bedrohung
nicht ernst genommen wurde. Und wir sehen
das auch heute wieder.
Erst im April erklärte der Verfassungsschutz
in Sachsen gegenüber dem MDR, es lägen keine
Erkenntnisse vor, dass QAnon Aktivitäten
im Freistaat Fuß fassten.
– Aber mit einer fünf
Minuten Suche konnte ich ganz schnell das
Gegenteil finden. Es gibt auf Telegram eigene
QAnon-Sachsen-Kanäle, die AfD Landkreis Leipzig
teilt QAnon-Beiträge und mehrere Menschen
in QAnon-Gruppen sagen, dass sie aus Sachsen
kommen.
Braut sich da etwas zusammen, das die Behörden
nicht im Blick haben?
Pia Lamberty fürchtet, dass aus der QAnon-Verschwörungserzählung
auch in Deutschland Gewalt erwachsen kann:
Wer wirklich glaubt, dass es diese Netzwerke
gibt, dann denkt man, man muss was machen
Wenn ich vor ein paar Jahren
ein Vortrag gehalten hab, dann war meistens
die Reaktion: "Ach Verschwörungstheorien Die sind ja so lustig. Diese Reaktionen bekomme
ich jetzt nicht mehr. Und dass es noch einmal
echten Effekt der Corona Pandemie, dass auf
einmal das nah gekommen, auf einmal ist das
Thema Verschwörung sehr persönlich geworden.
– I'm just an Anon.
Habt ihr in Eurem Umfeld jetzt häufiger
mit Verschwörungstheorien zu tun?
Wir freuen uns auf eure Sicht und eure Geschichten.
Schreibt uns in die Kommentare.